- Also there is some sad news.
I know that you were
really close with Betty.
And I know that you worked
with her in "Hot in Cleveland",
and so do you remember the
first time you met her?
- The first time I met
her was at the reading,
the very first script reading
for "Hot in Cleveland".
And I was in awe.
You've met Betty.
- I actually never met Betty.
No.
- I can't believe that.
- I never met Betty White.
No.
- Oh my God.
- I know.
And I'm such a huge fan, but yeah.
- When you're in her
presence, she literally glows.
I'm telling you, I don't know how,
but the woman is just
a walking glow stick.
Like she's just full of
gratitude and love and kindness.
She was just the greatest gift.
- When you've been in
the industry for so long.
And then you,
so y'all just met on "Hot in Cleveland"?
- Yeah, back (stammers)
- Were you still floored?
- Oh my God, yes.
I mean, Betty's been amazing for 99 years.
(interviewee laughs)
- I know, I was so mad.
'Cause I was like really?
Just shy of a hundred.
That was-
- But that's Betty.
Betty's got the best timing.
Why not send 2021 out with a bang?
Say see you later.
- Yeah.
- I'm out.
- She's like peace.
(both laugh)